el punto más alto en la tierra el monte
everest está a 8 400 kilómetros de
altura otra montaña en el mismo rango
cho oyu está ocho y medio kilómetros de
altura
escribe una desigualdad para mostrar la
relación entre estos dos puntos y
determinar qué punto es más alto
entonces veamos nos están diciendo que
el monte everest tiene una altura de 84
quintos de kilómetros y el cho oyu está
a 8 y medio kilómetros aquí tenemos las
alturas de los dos montes tenemos un
signo de igual y un mayor que como nos
están pidiendo determinar cuál es más
alto pues tendremos que usar el símbolo
mayor que debido a que sus alturas son
distintas y ahora veamos qué número es
más grande 81
84 quintos bueno pues en este caso el 8
es común y luego tenemos fracciones con
diferente denominador pero de alguna
manera podemos observar y hacer una
conversión relativamente sencilla para
encontrar un común denominador entre
medios y quintos podemos hacer un común
denominador con 10 que es el producto de
2 y 5
a un medio y yo lo multiplicó en el
denominador y en el numerador por 5
obtengo cinco décimos y cuatro quintos
si yo lo multiplicó por dos en el
denominador y en el numerador obtengo
ocho décimos entonces cinco décimos y
ocho décimos pues resulta que el de ocho
décimos o cuatro quintos es mayor
entonces veamos vamos a poner 84 quintos
nuestro símbolo de mayor que recuerda
que en el símbolo mayor que el número
mayor está del lado donde el signo tiene
esta apertura
ponemos el 8 medios y después veamos
84 quintos en la altura que corresponde
al monte everest así que la altura del
monte everest es mayor que la altura del
monte cho oyu
y observamos nuestras respuestas y es la
segunda la que está aquí el monte
everest es más alto y comprobamos
nuestra respuesta muy bien hagamos uno
más
muy bien aquí nos dice que john está
haciendo masa para pasta para hacer la
masa mezclo uno tres quintos tazas de
harina de trigo con 715 a dos tazas
regular y algo de agua escribe una
desigualdad para expresar la relación
entre la harina de trigo y la harina
regular observemos 13 quintos y 715 a
vos quién es mayor bueno podríamos
observar que en el caso de los 715 años
pues un entero son 15 15 a vos y 7 15
años pues es menor que un entero en este
caso
la harina de trigo pues es un entero
tres quintos definitivamente es mayor
uno tres quintos que 715 años
ahora vamos a seleccionar nuestra
respuesta
13 quinto tazas es mayor que 7 15 años
de taza comprobamos nuestra respuesta
muy bien vamos a hacer uno más
otra vez john está haciendo masa para
pasta y para hacer la masa mezclo tres
medios de taza de harina de trigo con
tres cuartos tazas de harina regular y
algo de agua escribir una desigualdad
para expresar la relación entre la
harina de trigo y la harina regular
observemos otra vez la harina de trigo
son tres medios de taza y tenemos tres
cuartos de taza de harina regular y con
un poco de observación podemos ver que
un entero tiene dos medios así que tres
medios es mayor que un entero de hecho
es un entero un medio tres cuartos un
entero tiene cuatro cuartos así que tres
cuartos es menor que un entero así que
tres medios es mayor que tres cuartos
tres y medio tazas
mayor que tres cuartos de taza
comprobamos nuestra respuesta perfecto
todo salió muy bien